health
well that is physics isn't it hello
everyone
we're here chatting with my beloved son
favorite son I never told him that you
know got three sons but he's my favorite
one but please don't tell the others
what do we have today well the first
thing I want to remind you is that we
have a conference in Buenos Aires on the
10th of November Saturday and we already
got by people at least signed up now try
to get a couple more see if I can
resolve Mike hunters problem for those
who know who know Mike he's a great guy
and I'm gonna try to get him down there
and I'll see if I can solve some of the
problems some of the obstacles he's got
we can make it merrier but you know one
of the things I found out in my
experience is that when you have a small
group five or six seven that's the best
group to have when you have these big
conferences a hundred people you know
one guy has one idea they only discuss
for a couple seconds then you go off
talk to another guy you don't get to say
no what no it's too many people to to be
able to to resolve things yeah on the
other hand when you have like a quality
circle six seven eight people oh that's
great because they throw [ __ ] at each
other and that's the best that's the
best so I recommend that each one of you
bring your own baseball bat okay Melkor
thing or three is better than two but
that's the point
yeah it starts going back down once
there's too many voices too many cooks
spoil the pot yeah and a good group is
six or seven I think that's more or less
what it's gonna come down to in born
Osiris and that's when you learn you
learn because you have a small group and
this is a very intelligent group I vouch
for it there are sharp people you may
not agree with everything they say so
they're not crazy but they're not crazy
all right
in the right way and so this is this is
a something you really don't want to
miss and I know this from previous
conferences that we had you get a lot
more in or a lot more out from very few
people because you see all these
diverging views you change ideas and
it's very dynamic very very profitable
really it is so I urge you to go to
Buenos Aires and you know pitch in your
version and be confronted by people who
don't agree with you and that's where
the fun begins you're gonna have good
food as a background good side Buenos
Aires is kind of nice and depends on
what you like to see if you like fishing
well bring your fishing rod you don't
need a license down there to catch fish
if you like history well there's a lot
of sights to see I can show you around
because I'm a history buff and so on and
so forth it depends on what you really
want to see you want to see Gauchos in
go to san antonio de areco
they have Gaucho environment over there
if you want to know you know what the
Argentine cowboy looks like or does or
whatever if you want tango you know
tango the dance a couple places a little
expensive quite pricey but very nice
very very nice
vacation yeah tourist agencies anyways
for those of you who want to go you're
not gonna waste your money it's gonna be
a good vacation for you if you go and so
yeah I do urge you to go down there here
it is just in case where is it here I've
got it artist this is the six rational
physics conference on the 10th of
November okay and it's hosted by David
Robinson and myself and you know we're
gonna be there and we're gonna talk
about physics about the Rope model okay
so those of you who want to join us this
is the time to put all these questions
in okay what were we talking about well
we were talking about you know
rationality and the bottom line is that
I was criticizing I was saying that
mathematical physics in general and
quantum mechanics in particular are not
rational why aren't the irrational okay
if it's a set of criteria and the first
one essentially is the most important
one and that's that you know you can't
use concepts as physical objects you
can't talk about wave functions you
can't talk about probability waves and
call them particles to confuse the
audience particle sounds like a physical
logic like a corpuscle and a
wavefunction is not one at all it's it's
an equation and so you can't say that in
equations what you accelerate along a
beam line and crash it against another
you know probability wave or whatever
and that's where we have a problem we
have wrong with the language you can't
transfer energy you can't move a mass
you can't carry a force or an
interaction
you can't dilate time etc etc etc and
this is where the problem is the problem
is in the language this is not a
semantic or semantical problem or
argument or that you can dismiss and say
well you you're raising semantics bill
no this goes to the heart or was the
person who's saying what is your theory
are you really saying that you're
accelerating a wave particle a wave
function
along the beam line and if you're not
please tell me what physical object
you're transferring and or accelerating
and what does it look like
and you might say what's the relevance
of that and there is a relevance if
you're gonna pull two quarks together
and you're gonna do it with glue on
particles well there's no way you can do
it unless maybe they're hook shaped or
something you know elastic which is what
we shown last week the gluons are you
know these elastic rubber bands
Bubblegum's that stretch out is that
what a gluon is well have you put the
mathematicians against the ropes you
know against the the wall he's gonna
deny it he's about no that's not what
they are we just simulate we just
physically represent it this way
pictorially you represent it this way to
bring it down to your level that's
that's the argument that they have and
you say okay don't bring it down to my
level what the hell are you really
saying are you saying that the gluon is
a is a bubblegum if not what is a gluon
is it a little particle a discrete
little ball if it's a discreet little
ball how do you produce attraction
between two quarks and what they do the
answer is in Reverse it's well well we
try to push or pull two quarks apart the
farther you try to pull them out apart
the more energy you need and we're
saying that all these gluons are kind of
being stretched or pulling on them and
so it takes more energy and that's what
we're physically or we or pictorially
representing when we stretch a gluon and
use a rubber band or a bubblegum and
again it's it's a twisted they're the
ones doing semantics there are the ones
who are twisting the language to try to
get their theory through they do not
have a physical interpretation for what
they're saying they do not have a theory
because a theory is an explanation
anyways the deal that we had is that
first we had criteria for what a what
rationale is because what
about rational science compared to
irrational science or irrational
anything irrational is under religion
and we had a little debate here with ons
you know he disagrees with all my some
of my criteria or some of my general
notions we and it's good to have
differences because then we get to the
bottom of what the problem is what the
obstacle is and one of those was whether
the criteria that I'm using is objective
now as standalone I don't think he's
criticizing and I think if you look at
the first one concepts being used as
objects I think we all agree that's
irrational but that's not the point
that's not his point his point of
something else this point is that
another person which I call a religious
person
he might disagree with my choice of
criteria you say Oh hold it hold it you
chose that criteria because it favors
your religion your religion okay so I'm
saying how do we resolve these issues is
there an objective way to resolve this
and now we get to the word objective now
we have the fight over the forward not
rationality but objective what is
objective what is subjective and I'd put
a little analogy to try to put it within
focus and this is my analogy my analogy
is there's two boxers the champ and the
contender champ eats the you know living
crap out of the contender that
contenders on the floor begging for his
life and then the champ says I am the
champ I'm the winner of this bout and
the other guys on the floor you know was
bleeding and with no teeth anymore and
he said no I'm the champ I'm the winner
well you can't be the winner because
objectively the guy who's standing is
the winner that's my argument okay
that's my first argument least and and
so this goes more and more and more
there there's more to it than just that
but that's my analogy I'm saying if if
the guy remains standing the other guys
on the floor you can't say be on the
floor all bleeding and say that you're
the champ
that's my point and use the extreme
difference hold on there
because we're talking about a sport yeah
yeah I was a distinction I made about a
gamer a sport the wind conditions at
least within the game are clear whether
you think you won or because it's a
moral victory for you - or because you
were doing it to gain money let's
clarify that let me clarify that because
people may not understand everything
that you're saying there let's assume
let's assume that you wanted to lose the
fight just just for the sake of argument
okay maybe you bet on on you lose e yeah
for example just an extreme example here
just to make our point the point is the
following you're on the floor you lost a
fight you got you're all bleeding up and
you say I won what do you mean you won
you're on the floor you lost well that's
as far as the bout is concerned but
maybe you had some other thing going on
maybe you bet against yourself and you
want a million dollars because you lost
the fight and you say I'm the winner
you have no teeth you got no eyes you
know you can't see anymore but I'm the
winner
why are you the winner because you lost
the bout but you won the war you got
what you were aiming for right and
that's someone subjective and what we're
saying and what I'm saying at least is
that you know the guy who remains
standing is objectively the winner well
no it's not objectively the winner it's
what about the purposes of sport for
them okay so we gotta clarify then I
guess objectively is the right word
because it's it's like objectively in
the sense that okay we all agreed on my
definition or by definition there's a
guy who's stand the rule we all agreed
on these rules so now from now on this
is what we call boxing okay but it's
kind of a vote thing but we're gonna put
that aside for now we're just gonna say
this is what we all call boxing the
other rules but essentially we're saying
these are the rules to call it boxing
these are rules within boxing to call
you the winner so then the game there's
no there's no there's no there's a be
two winners right can be two losers
no no but I'm talking about some clear
one guy stands the other guy you got a
simple within the game there's gonna be
a winner yeah and it doesn't matter who
says is the winner but according to
their rules according to the rules that
have been already said there is gonna be
a winner within the game but that's
that's the that's the game sense of
winning right you play chess with
someone there are clear rules that is
once someone takes the other ones king
when someone loses the king they're the
loser by definition definition aliens
the winner right but that has nothing to
do with the subjective form of winner
where you say we're not looking at what
you were aiming for
because again you could have been aiming
for money you could have anything for
fame you could have lost or maybe yeah
or it could be that I think I just
wanted to fight as far as he's concerned
he's happy that he got to meet the
champion of the world even if he lost
for him it's a victory because all he
had a different goal in mind yeah but
within the game it's clear yeah
general loser yeah once you lose your
queen that game
and so what I'm saying is the Queen the
king but the point here that I'm trying
to make is that then we have to
establish
like I said here you know we have to
establish the rules of science and by
this I mean the rules of rational
science what rationally what we're going
to consider rational insight I think the
better way to say it is we have to come
up with the rules for the sport of
science okay let's call it the sport of
science the game of science any way you
want to look at it we have to come up
with some kind of rules and and I'm
saying you to declare it rational or
irrational
what a guy proposes if a person proposes
a theory that is irrational you know we
have to wait have a way of rejecting
that by the rules by by the objectively
and what I'm saying is the you know I've
created some criteria and I'm sure a lot
of people not only you know I know a lot
of people pose this and they oppose it
because they're trying to protect the
religion primarily because they know
that if those rules stand they lose they
lose the bout they lose the discussion
and they don't like those rules and so
what I'm saying here is that you have
two choices you either confront the
rules and you can do one of two things
you can add or you can subtract if you
have some rule and we just came up one
out of the blue and we said look ratchet
oh is anything that is red okay fine if
we can't find any fault with that rule
with that clause we allow it we say okay
we have another clause another rule for
the game of science yeah but you know
you just said yeah we can't find fault
well yeah Yankee means we both agree on
the word no we don't agree we just the
guy who opposes that can't find anything
wrong then he's got to swallow the the
reality can't find anything wrong code
for I'll vote on this criteria no no he
can't vote against that's the point why
not
because he can't find any fault with he
can't come up with any arguments he
can't come up any arguments in his head
that I mean maybe today maybe tomorrow
he comes up with one but today as of the
moment of the conference the guy can't
come up with an argument against that
rule and so he says okay I was to say I
gotta go home and work on it on my
blackboard yeah but who's to say let's
see he gives an argument an argument
yeah but then again that's a dumb
argument that he's making that's what is
and again it's a it's a back and forth
because the other guy is gonna say
that's a dumb Marga why is it a dumb are
you because of this or Modine no we're
not voting again we're making arguments
against with the other guys proposing an
but in both directions by the way yeah
yeah but arguments is is code for in
this case is it code for well I'll let
this one slide we'll take this one
except except some things are patently
obvious and again you know you know no
you can take us to the end of the earth
yeah but that's the point I mean I can
get a downs patient down spacian you
know he doesn't understand anything he
can come up with anything anything you
say or maybe he doesn't know maybe
there's an [ __ ] like me no just
disagrees for the sake of yeah yeah but
that's good that's good but my point is
if you have a downs patient you know
someone who doesn't have a mental
capacity and he comes up with idiocy you
know well I can't help what did you know
is the bottom of that yummy what does
that mean you can't help him do you stop
well no no no what I'm saying is no what
I'm saying as here we have an objective
statement for example I think yeah
concepts cannot be converted into object
or treated as objects that's a
straightforward statement and its
objective by itself there's no
subjectivity in that but we're
criticizing whether that criteria is
valid to determine our rationality
that's what we're doing there right
we're we're saying is that a valid
criterion and and so someone will object
to it someone will say well I don't like
that obviously it destroys his religious
but he's gonna complain you know he's
gonna say look I like spirits I want to
use Spears I want to use consciousness
and you know I want to be able to move
consciousness around and you say well
you can't do that not in physics because
consciousness is a concept you can't say
I moved consciousness from A to B and a
guy insists and so so there's a debate
there's a debate whether you can use
love consciousness information
the other concept and that you can start
moving them around and so so now we have
a serious fight yeah it goes on and and
and questions whether you know you can
say well that's all Indian and opinion
well for example we've got to get up to
a consensus well okay but I'm the guy
yeah yeah but the guy has to be able to
defend his posture he can't just say he
does with it yeah but then again you got
to show that it's a dumb argument yeah
but to whom to him is one fruit no I
don't want specific example yeah my
arguments gonna be that you're gonna
keep pounding him and he's gonna keep
he's gonna keep putting trenches and
backing off and putting trenches and
backing off and so the question is you
know he's specific let's do a mock up
can you think that's what we do every
day with where it's a debate well no
what I'm saying is you say is rule we
have a concept right and come you know
the tricity is a kind of setting you're
not gonna move objects to the concepts
but I am right and you're gonna move
electricity you know that tricity is a
concept
okay and so you're gonna say I always
say that you're at that first definition
okay and sorry and so I'm gonna say
please define electricity because if
it's a concept
I need a definition if it's an object
you just point to it and say this is
this is a dog this is a tree this is a
rock no problem but it'll just to define
concepts that would be my argument but
then what are you talking about what is
this word that you say I never heard of
it I'm proud I'm from Mars I don't know
what Alec tripley's the final
electricity because I've never what is
this where is it go word while we're at
it and this means is being a douche yeah
devil's advocate is why I'm telling you
this is exactly what you expect where
electricity conference what do you mean
you don't know what eletricity that's
the response you probably yeah yeah but
see this is the point the point is that
you and that's where the the
negotiations break down and then we're
done
no no I'm saying that what you do is you
bombard the guy until the guy finally
break no no but I'm saying what is
already yeah and the guys I'm not gonna
define it then we have a problem because
again we have to you can't use undefined
words as a second criterion and he's
gotta find he's gotta find a way of
saying that he's not gonna accept that
criterion yeah yeah but you don't like
his opinion that you need to have a
reasoning it's unscientific criteria
yeah but you gotta have a read can't
just declare and state that's my point
you gotta argue for you gotta fight
you're gonna put your lever you're
missing it because it's still a vote
issue where we tell you get out of
science yeah the guy gets weird out of
saying because because the guy the guy
only has opinions and opinions is under
religion by definition otherwise the
guy's just gonna have to define science
in a different way and religion in them
we go to a lower level where the guy
says well no science is not about
explaining it's not about rational
explanation he's got to go to that
Loewen if you disagree without all funds
but then you gotta then you got to go to
a lower level or a more basic level
where we did define not where
rationality is because obviously we
can't you know reach in some kind of
consensus there the issue is now you go
to a lower level or what is science what
is physics you know is is science about
explaining things rationally and the guy
says well no I don't agree and and in
fact that's what the mathematicians
would say they say it's about describing
and that's where the problem is the
problem is in fact it is at a lower
level like I'm saying here you know
that's where the fight is going to be
and the question is and then you know
you can use an example like I use I'm
sitting here you have two magnets right
and they attract here they repel okay
they don't like each other and the
question is if this phenomenon is a part
of physics
but it is not does this phenomena in the
explaining what is happening here how
one magnet is that part of physics or
not and if people say you know you you
it's a yes or no okay
it either is or it's not yeah dropping a
pen or whatever here I have a pen
dropping a pen you know I let go of it
it falls to the center of the earth to
the floor to whatever right is the
explanation of that phenomenon a part of
physics and the question is will the
mathematician say what if I say no right
he might say no it's not and again then
he's gotta define what is math what is
what is physics what is science about
that you just did yeah but he might say
it's math and then the question is well
again I'm saying I need to understand or
people want to understand you know what
what brings this to the center of the
earth what brings a magnet towards
another they go to theology you're in
the wrong yeah but yeah but then again
and and that's where it comes down and
that's why yeah yeah no no it's got a
vote it just oh no no no I'm saying it's
not a vote I'm saying that we're gonna
do science and whatever they do is
whatever they do
welcome together which I mean the way I
understood it is sciences is we're all
trying to collectively understand what
you the universe is trying to do right
or how the universe works
well isn't this how the universities
yeah yeah but I mean what do we mean by
how are we saying how or why in other
words are we asking for a mechanism or
are we just gonna describe and say oh
you know the pen falls on 9.8 meters per
second squared I mean is that just a
description it's just saying that a
chair has one backrest four legs and two
arm Rus is that is that what science is
about just describing saying oh that's
what a chair is yes or is it or is it
about it
please some phenomenon such as invisible
stuff like you know what is light how
does light do its magic how does a
magnet do it's magic how does gravity do
its well that's what we want to
understand but I mean I thought that's I
thought that's what we wanted to
understand but then if if understanding
is the is the goal understanding how the
universe does their tricks how hydrogen
at hydrogen what hydrogen atoms
theoretically look like well you would
think to see the unseen is the goal
you'd think you would think yeah I mean
I that's the way I look at it but that's
not the way they look at it they don't
want to see the unseen they say the
unseen is unseeable but but assuming
assuming that is the goal okay I'm
seeing you know I'm not just I mean they
also want to see the unseen and the
Sestak because they're looking at the at
the effects of the unseen and you're
trying to figure out the shape of the
yeah well you get a start you get a
start with a shape because you gotta try
to identify what an object is you know
what it you know I mean we're talking
about the atom what are we talking about
and hopefully you know the first thing
you want to do is illustrate the atom
your atom not that the real item but
your M but when you're proposing the one
you're gonna explain your theory with
your you know what your dissertation is
about and so the first thing you do is
present your atom you would think okay
you know like if just let me give you a
simpler example you say you know the
three knocked down my house I'm gonna
explain a theory where the tree fell and
broke my house okay so video but see I'm
explaining it to the Martian and he
doesn't know what a tree is or what my
house is so the first thing I think I
would do to get them you know more or
less a picture of what I'm trying to
tell them is so look this is what we
call tree and this is what we call a
house so you point to these things and
say this is tree this is
this is what I think happened to
pre-fill on doubt very simple fell on
you define right and and and and and you
would think that all physical phenomena
are explained in the same way and if the
guy just says look I'm just gonna say
that there was a force of so many meters
for a square inch or whatever you know
that caused the house to fall you know
nobody's going to understand that unless
you really put a some kind of object
there unless you pictorially represent
what you're talking about
well is it and that's where the problem
is is that what you said yesterday in
the kitchen the most pressing issue on
this where you said that all these years
these two thousand years of doing
science have all just been trying to
figure out what is science you know we
had a discussion yesterday after our
president our lecture and you know I'm
telling on tear that you know maybe
maybe these last two thousand three
thousand years the whole process we call
science or research or whatever you want
to call it was to find out what the
rules of science are what the rules of
the scientific method are now we have
them and now we go back and say this is
scientific this was not or that kind of
thing but it kinda goes to that where
that's kind of what we're hoping around
yeah yeah we're trying to is this weird
thing work to understand how the
universe works you kind of need a system
I mean we have to run the scientific
method that's kind of like the crowning
achievement of science it isn't so much
what we learned is more the process by
which we discern the rules of the game
rules of the game or the process that we
call science so with with we're trying
to have this it's like anytime here you
don't have stringent rules on what
you're doing is kind of up in the air so
you can't really what follow
why are you kind of like you're on
attention yeah why you're not doing
science you think they're doing science
but you're not
okay that's the question why is it that
we need these specific rules to kind of
or how do they help us see their help or
we can't do without to understand the
University and what I'm saying is the
answer to that question is that if you
define the terms rigorously you say this
is what science is this is what the
scientific method is if science is
rational explanation what do you mean by
explanation what do you mean by
rationale etc you define the crucial
words in what you're saying and you got
to go slowly because you really got to
go through each one of these words and
people well first of all dismiss all
that and say oh you're doing semantics
you're doing metal metaphysics or
ontology or whatever
no you're defining the foundations in
this case of physics you could do that
for philosophy as well but what what
you're doing is defining the foundations
of physic you're saying look if it
doesn't meet these conditions heat the
Specht specifications then you're not
doing physics you're not doing sci-fi
and the guy and the guy and the guys
gonna because you reject his theory is
religion because it's irrational and the
guy is gonna object to that he doesn't
he's not gonna like it
obviously he said look I all my life I
believed in this and you're trying to
reject it with semantics you know but
finding words to put it in and that's my
whole deal let me finish that's why we
have to get on top of the ring and fight
it out and find out what the rules of
the game are and we have to develop the
rules of the game so we say this is
science and discipline have been
developing yeah we don't know I have to
agree and we will not all agree
obviously because of some religions are
going to be trounced so obviously we're
not going to agree to put this into
perspective in boxing for example yeah
why do we have rules because there's
someone pulls out a gun in the middle of
the fight and shoots the other guy he's
not the winner the winner runs the sport
it's like oh we all it's like you
cheated yeah
but what does that mean so you
one the whole point we're here for or or
or someone in the audience I hate that
guy I think that's a more nuanced thing
but in chess if I just go on and smack
your king away uh-oh so the game was to
kill your king I did - but the point is
what why do we have rules in sport
versus a woman you can specifically say
what are the things that would ruin the
whole point we're here the very good
point there well he was just saying you
know if I knock your king out I can
knock your king out I won't do it
legally I won't do it by the rules I'll
just go quick
and knock your king out of there say I
won because the game says he who knocks
the other guys came out and I did it see
I think you came out but you bypassed
seven rules right and so the question is
that what we want is that kind of
cheating acceptable so we do have to
have some kind of rule not eating
acceptable okay it's more specifically
okay why is cheating unacceptable
because you're ruining the whole point
where you basically wasted our time
yeah and let me put that in the context
of science let me put that into context
I'm someone someone where the rules of
science someone brings spirits in there
okay and he says oh yeah the reason the
curtain moved is my grandmother spirit
is in the room and she moved the curtain
and you say no no look it's it's the
window that's open the air came in just
moved it you thick curtain what do you
mean no no it's my mother spirit or my
grandmother spirit because she loves me
and today's her birthday and she came in
to visit me and she goes through this
theory and you say well hold it you're
cheating because what do you mean by
spirit what do you mean that you're a
grandmother spirit I thought she died
well she's alive but she's not alive
physically she's alive spiritually and
so now we get into this war of what do
you mean by spirit can you illustrate it
is this a concept this is an object we
get into what people call semantics and
it is semantics in in that sense but the
guys using
semantics is the other guy the guide is
introducing you know a word that is not
acceptable and that's gonna be
challenged but the point is that why is
it cheating or unacceptable for someone
but that's my point
why is it unacceptable for someone to
evoke spirits or you know spirits right
to answer it
that's not accept because it's a Matt
John explaining it he's he's ruining the
whole point we even brought up the
question yeah because if you're gonna do
something by magic well we don't need
physics you're basically saying I think
they're right I don't care how it's done
I'm just gonna invent magic how does the
particle put on pull on another particle
that's far away well God brings his
magic one goes abracadabra and it does
so okay well yeah I can do physics like
that to say playing Monopoly what
happened yeah what happened a guy's
money is okay we're not playing Monopoly
anymore right right and so we're gonna
do science okay I call that GD can it's
cheating if we really want to know I
don't know how magnets work we really
want to know right right now you can't
you can't just pull something out of
your ass and say all right what it is
who cares and then just leave the room
and and that's the point the point is
that if you're gonna use magic black
magic then it's not science it's not
physics and yeah you can do physics with
magic but then you're not doing physics
you're doing religion and and when you
turn a concept into an object and start
pushing it around like saying oh we
accelerated and smashed particles he
said okay what does your particle look
like well it's not really a particle
corpuscle which is what you you're
thinking of no it's really a
wavefunction and what do you mean by
wavefunction well look at the this is
the equation and what do you mean any
quasar you accelerating equations and
smashing equations so the guy's not
doing anything that's rational anymore
and that's that's why that's why we have
to put in there the rule and say look if
you're gonna start accelerating and
smashing concepts such as equations or
functions or variables or numbers we got
a problem
and the problem is that you need to be
locked up in an asylum issue okay
understanding kind of the title of the
video yeah yeah we're we're all here to
understand how the universe works right
yeah but we could both understand it
with conflicting theories yeah and let
me give a little background there last
night after we finished the lecture we
wanted to get to the bottom of the words
explain and understand what my son I'm
not sure we reached any conclusion so so
don't hold your breath today okay we're
still brainstorming here but the issue
that came up was whether science was
about explaining or about understanding
and I believe or I hold the position
that science is about explaining
rational explanations and my dear son
here he says no it's about understanding
and so that's where we had a discussion
a very long discussion and the issue is
you know what do we mean by explain what
do we mean by understand and one of the
ways you can try to resolve this is by
looking up the words in the dictionary
let me show you what the definition the
official definition you know in
dictionary at least the one for ordinary
speech is for for what an explanation is
this is what explain means to make plain
or clear render understandable explain
directly related to understanding or
intelligible to explain an obscure point
example their right to make known in
detail to explain explain this to
explain okay great to assign a meaning
to is meaning the same thing as
explained well that's debatable as well
I mean we have definitions and meaning
we have explanations and meaning is the
meaning the word meaning used
consistently when we address when we
oppose it to explain as when we oppose
it to define
and that's another issue to make clear
the cause or reason of a cause or reason
that kind I like because that fourth one
there because that does relate to what
we do in science cause physics reason
philosophy so I kind of like that count
for I cannot well I gave an example I
cannot explain this strange behavior and
let's explain let's look at real quick
let's look at what we mean by understand
here's the official definition of
understand and there's several things
that you'll see in the dictionary
dictionary.com to perceive the meaning
of sounds quite a bit like what we just
heard meaning and they bring meaning
again and again are we saying
understanding is the opposite of
definition or the same as a definition
what are we saying here
grasp the idea of comprehend comprehend
as a synonyms as they understand and
comprehend were saying the same thing
and they gave the example to understand
Spanish I didn't understand your
question etc to be thoroughly familiar
with apprehend again another synonym to
assign a meaning to to grass
significance again significance more or
less understanding synonyms - regardless
firmly communicated now that's getting a
little better to regard as communicated
but see we got a problem there because
you can explain right and the other guy
says I didn't understand so you
explained and maybe you went out of your
way Jake Spain you even made a movie and
this what my argument is I made a movie
of my theory and the guy who says well
you know you did not communicate your
theory very well to me and you say well
what problem do you have the movie that
I made I mean what part in the movie did
you not understand what is is there a
missing piece there that you didn't
understand yeah you get a focus and ask
questions until the guy understands what
the mechanism that you illustrate the
problem the problem with that one is to
regard as communicated is is is it the
explainer could say oh I've come
you can't say they don't know but that's
that question that's my point the
questions my point that there with that
one it falls through because it depends
on who says that they regarded as
communicated that's why it falls through
no by saying that I nominate explainer
doesn't leave the room until the guy the
other guy shows what part he did not
understand in the whole process
he can't say I didn't understand any of
it no you can't say that because if the
guy makes a move you say no no no you
you just have an opinion and you it
destroys your religion and that's the
only reason you say you don't understand
tell me what parts specifically in the
movie in the movie what part of my miss
you say you're missing a part here okay
okay let me explain that part let me
illustrate that part for you until the
guy understands there's no way the guy
can continue saying forever I didn't
understand I didn't understand I didn't
understand no understand doesn't mean
that you believe it just means you
understood what the guy is proposing not
that you agree with it
yeah that's why that one falls through
because no it doesn't fall through
because you can ask no no million garden
is for me firmly communicate you say you
say it's a good definition
no no that's Walter no I'm not saying
it's a good definitely I'm and I say how
it falls through I'm saying it
approaches it approaches better than the
others to say that you assigned a
meeting buddy that's no wrong some short
because the regard is communicated
depends on who regards that is coming
this is not a question of that's my
point
- I'm defending your point you're not
getting me okay let's see regard is
firmly communicated yeah shitty
definition okay right because it falls
through it depends on who regards it as
communicated that agree with that why
okay okay I'm saying that's why falls
through because okay I'm just saying if
Johnny says it's regarded as can be in
the round I didn't understand it right I
didn't understand it but Johnny over
there says oh yeah I regard it as
community right and and so what I'm
saying is the guy can't continue saying
I didn't understand I didn't understand
I didn't understand now if you make a
movie of a mechanism how to pull a pail
with a pulley you know you say this is
the way you do it you pull on the road
by the little wheel turns and pull the
pill up
and the guy can't say why I didn't
understand well what part didn't you
understand you know please tell me
specifically what part you didn't
understand and I'll clarify it for you
and the guy said what do you understand
this little thing and then you say okay
what part didn't you understand about
that and and you keep pinching the guy
until the guy says okay finally I
understood he can't continue forever say
I didn't understand I didn't understand
I didn't understand because that's only
that only means he's just a devil's
advocate or he you're destroying his
religion and he doesn't like it or
whatever yeah yeah yeah you got a we got
a doves patient there in front of you
you know he's not gonna understand no
matter what you do can you bring up the
definitions for explaining yeah okay no
whoa I wanted to bring up my definition
okay where was it explained here
there's the explained definition to make
plain or clear again that's not so but
there's a difference they do make a
distinction interestingly because we all
not understand the definition the the
the difference between explain and
understand yes is two people or one
person with explain it's me to you with
understand it's always just to here to
take in is me with myself while with the
explain it's always me to someone else
and all well again and we had a debate
about that last night because what what
does a person do a person tries to
explain some phenomena something
happened right magnets could be right
when a magnet attracts another what do
we do well we we might brainstorm things
we can say God sent His angels and push
them together okay that's one
possibility
what's another we have particles that
somehow deliver negative momentum or
whatever you have all these ideas thrown
in there so we'll say we'll call that a
brainstorming session we brainstorm
ideas right so we have I don't know say
ten things on the board we lock them
down all these are explanations but you
haven't chosen one all you did was
brainstorm just everything that came to
mind you just put on the board anything
is valid because brainstorming accepts
anything
in Portuguese no basically means
no-holds-barred for it yeah in other
words everything everything is Valerie
then goes yeah everything goes and and
that's the issue brainstorming you just
put explanations on the board period
will you put them up there now at the
end of the brainstorming session you
might choose one you might you might
reject them all for all we know you know
but you might say look out of all these
I think this is the best one that I like
and maybe you didn't hit the right one
maybe it's not the one for example that
mother nature uses to run her shop but
that's the one you chose you like that
one for whatever reason your education
your way you the way you were up you
know your upbringing your biases your
you know your different ways of thinking
whatever and so you chose one and so now
you're gonna explain to someone else you
can say look the reason you know this
phenomenon happens is because of this
and you just give them the one that you
chose okay so the guy now is going to
try to understand comprehend what you
said and what you say that is not just
what you said but you're gonna
illustrate it because if we're talking
about physics you're gonna have you you
should be able to illustrate your theory
and so you you make an illustration you
make a little movie of your theory
because that's what a theory is a movie
of objects and you say look what's the
movie the god watches the movie and he
says I don't understand and so now the
question is not whether you believe
we're talking about understanding out
about believing and we're saying okay
what part did you not understand and
said well how did you get from point A
to C here oh you're you're missing B
okay so now you fill in the blank and
again you make a movie and you show how
you get from A to B and then from B to C
and the guy can't just continue
bombarding you because we're not talking
about believing he
agree with you that's right and you
don't have to agree we're just talking
about the guy understanding what you're
proposing and you say okay now I
understand your theory and that's all
we're talking about we're talking about
understanding and I'm saying that you
know I can't vouch for the other guy all
I can do is explain and if I'm missing a
piece fine the guy questions me and says
well I didn't understand this part okay
what part did you for example I'll give
you a very good example that I've had
this week a couple times the guy says
what is the Rope made of electromagnetic
Road and I said Jesus this this was the
simplest thing in the world two strands
so the guy comes back and he says was it
made out of hemp is it made out of
you know what material is it a straw
what is it made out of so so he keeps
digging into something that is troubling
him okay something is troubling him he
wants to know what the ultimate material
that the rope or the thread or whatever
is made out of and and at some point you
say look the thread is an elementary a
fundamental entity or D demon right and
and you know these people have not been
trained to understand what elementary
fundamental means because the particle
mathematicians say oh the electron is an
elementary particle and and the reporter
asked him what is it made out of and
instead of saying look elementary means
it's not made of anything the guy ends
up saying well give me some money more
money so that I bigger make a bigger
atom smasher I'll smash the electron out
I'll tell you what it's made out of then
it's not an elementary particle like
that well what's the elementary particle
made of yeah definition
made of anything but and this is the
first and this this is the issue the
issues that people keep asking but it's
not that they're not understanding the
theory because the theory has nothing to
do with what the rope or what the
threads are made of let me finish this
thought it's not what they're made out
of the theory has nothing to do with
that but it's like they're nitpicking
you because they want to know something
else that's not embodied in the theory
the theory just says look if you have a
torsion of a rope that's light and do
you understand that much I mean I let's
not go any further do you understand
that I'm saying light is just a torsion
and and we were talking about that with
ours last night if if you turn on the
light you press a button and the light
goes on and so the guy says how does how
do you turn on the light and you say let
me explain it to you look you press the
button here and that light goes on now
that's all he explained he hasn't told
you anything about electricity he hasn't
talked to you about fields or anything
and he's of it he says look let me tell
you how that light turns on the light
turns on by pressing the button okay so
now you know how the light goes on you
just press the button now the guy has a
more basic or more fundamental question
says well hold it why does the light
turn on and so now you go into a little
deeper explanation you if you know the
answer you know you may not know the
answer you say look you might say look
there's all these atoms from here all
the way to the light and all these
electrons these beads and they flow from
atom to atom and they turn on the light
and so now you ask them another question
do you understand that much my proposal
my theory I think I might say yes but I
still don't understand how it is that
you know these electrons move now you go
to a deeper level you say this is what
causes them them and and so on and so
forth what I'm saying here is there are
different levels of understanding okay
layers of understand layers of
understanding I explained to the guy why
the light turns on I pressed the button
that's why the light turns on and that's
a very simple explanation and a lot of
people are comfortable with that they
say okay so I understand every time I
need to turn the light on all I got to
do with press this button okay I
understand
so if he understands that he understood
your theory at that level but that but
that we're going back to the nitpicking
guy he goes into that where it's not
really layers of understanding it's kind
of more I mean it's also layers but it's
also like a web because to understand
this thing I need to understand it that
thing yeah so that's why they kind of
want they're asking about the head thing
where you're like okay what's it made
out of they think I understood that it's
a rope yeah but that's the issue the
issue is they have to stop there and
then have you understood so far what
I've said so far so far but but the guy
came out of nowhere that's because they
went out they want to say well I didn't
understand this other thing well I
didn't explain that other thing so don't
ask me that
have you understood that light is this a
torsional arrow have you understood that
part and if the guy says yes okay I'm
finished
you wouldn't understand man you got to
come to the conference you know but
these guys want to get to the nitpicking
stuff but they don't ask that question
at the beginning they say so you're
saying that light is a rope well did you
understand that I'm not asking you to
believe I'm asking you do you understand
know what I'm saying that it's just a
torsion it's just a nice follow-up
question later follow-up is fine
follow-up is fine but what I'm saying is
I have explained what I'm proposing
let's put it in in quantum terms you ask
a quantum mathematician what is light
and that guy sets the flow of particles
will call them photons will come
whatever I don't care we can call it so
wait yeah yeah they don't hear either
and and have you understood the
mechanism yeah I understood it perfect I
can tell you I don't believe in it but I
understood it I can't say well I didn't
understand what do you mean it's a flow
of particle yeah it's a flow of party
that's what I'm gonna try to explain to
you can you understand this or not river
of bees right but the explanation is
right
but then there's someone you know yeah I
understand that part but since this is
like a web kind of thing of
understanding it's like well something
feels off about this rope thing because
it could be irrational of BS yeah if or
I would consider it irrational until I
know what it's made out until I know
fine but no different questions
bothering here all I'm saying here is
that if I ask a quondam guy you know
what is your explanation for light and
the guy said let me give you my physical
interpretation my physical
interpretation is that light consists of
a flow of particles
did you understand yes I understood
perfectly I can't say I didn't
understand that part yet
now if I want to know a follow-up
question I want to get to a deeper level
that's a separate question but I can't
say oh I didn't understand what do you
mean you didn't understand I'm a flow of
particles what part did you what part
that you would not understand the part
flow or the part particles let me know
it's a slower particle move it's like so
this is the issue if it's a different
question different answer a different
question right right yeah I think I
answered your first question nobody get
what you're saying my point is that when
I make the movie when I make the movie
of my theory I'm saying okay I'm gonna
explain quantum quantum light and the
guy said okay how do you explain light
and I say look and Adam just shoots all
these particles and we'll call them
photons and all these photons go
everywhere and that's what we call light
it just reaches your eye did you
understand the theory did you understand
my proposal did you understand my
explanation I can't say there I can't
say I didn't understand that now I can
say hold it but how do atoms create
photons that's understand on my theory
but maybe not because again
understanding a theory is at different
levels because I could ask the same
question and
and usually just say it's it's a spray
which is basically a part of notes
breath and we'll use it yeah it's a
spray that's like okay okay yeah I
understand that but okay did you
understand that
yeah they stop you there no because oh
you know what that wasn't my question
you didn't answer my question it's too
vague an answer no no but you're missing
the point the point is that I did answer
your question at the one level at one
love but it's not the level I wanted
correct correct but I understand it I I
realize that but what I'm saying is if a
guy tells you look what is your
mechanism for light and I say it's a
flow of particles you can't say why I
didn't understand that no no you can't
say that because that's my theory my
theory at that level is it's a flow of
particles now if you want to know
something else well how does the atom
create the particles or that's a
separate issue but you should be able to
understand that portion and say why I
didn't understand that yeah yes you you
can't just continue saying I didn't
understand I didn't understand I don't
know that it would go something like
yeah okay I got that part right
I mean separate quite right and then you
get to a deeper level and and and this
is the point the point is that you know
when when people say you know what is
your theory I'm saying well life is
light is a torsion of a rope all atoms
are interconnected I think I said I
didn't understand what do you mean you
know what part did you understand well
what is it made out of
that's a separate issue we're not
talking about that we're saying did you
understand the mechanism that I've been
explained to yeah everybody could listen
to you but it could come across like
facetious or you're just trying to get
them off your back look I can shift us
the thing whatever I could say is that
you could do it just as well saying
light is a thing I can say light is is
carried by angels did you understand my
theory my theory is that God sends
angels and each and luminous ball is an
angel I can say anything did you
understand my theory let's do it again
no no but with anything what is light
and you say light is a thing and then
you just walk away like that did you
understand it good you didn't you kind
of you listen a too vague a level the
the top layer no no you can say the
light is a thing and you haven't
answered the question you have
no no because you can't say light as a
thing because where it's a process you
gotta say look what I propose is that
invisible entity here is just a flow of
particles everybody should be under able
to understand I don't need to go to
college to understand that it's like
saying you know why did the why did the
tree grow well because I put water and
Earth into it and you can say okay I
understood that part and and then you
can go to a deeper level but that part
should be straightforward never have to
talk more about the layers of
understanding tomorrow yeah but again
what I'm saying is what I'm saying is
the top level of understanding you can't
just keep bugging the guide to death and
say I didn't understand what you meant
by the flow of particle I don't know
what you mean I love a particle you can
go and say you know how did the atom
create the particles that's a separate
issue but you can't say I didn't
understand flow of particles that's the
part I'm saying you can't question yeah
you can't say fine fine but if no no but
anyways if I go to you don't ask
anything I'm going to a to a conference
and I present my theory nobody has asked
me anything I'm just gonna present my
name I'm just gonna present my theory
and say my theory of light is that it
consists of a flow of party that was the
question and nobody asked me a question
or anything and people say well I didn't
understand that they can't say that it's
irrational to say I didn't understand
what you just explained they can't it's
it's irrational to ask that question or
to or to say I didn't understand a flow
of particles you can't say that now if
you want to know something else that's
separate but you can't say that you done
and understand flow of particles or
twisting of a rope you can and can't say
you'd understand that because then you
need to be locked up in an asylum that's
it and so I will see you tomorrow same
time same station we'll see you that
bye-bye